hello and um good morning good afternoon
good evening everybody
um I am sohaila from Ingenuity systems
we're part of college environformatics
and today I will be talking to you about
using ingenuities variant analysis a
platform that can be used for many
different types of analyzes for your
sequence variant data
so to start out I'm going to give you a
quick introduction of the platform and
the underlying knowledge base that we're
going to use to analyze the different
data sets and then I'll present four
different case studies where we have use
of application to narrow down to the
candidate variants for as either causal
mutations
or S targets for Therapeutics
so preparing analysis in a nutshell
is a secure web-based platform that is
used for interpreting Human Genome data
it is a flexible platform for annotating
and comparing different genomes it
allows for scientific iterations meaning
that if you decided to change your mind
about specific criteria or comparison
steps that you're using you can rerun
those
um in an iterative fashion within
minutes
it leverages the deepest functional
knowledge base that is available which
is the Ingenuity knowledge base
um but it also includes very rich cancer
specific annotations for analyzing uh
somatic data
it has robust analytical and statistical
methods that are built in for different
types of studies so either you're just
comparing a bunch of programs to
controls or you could have two normal
samples you could have large kindreds or
big cohorts um
with a quantitative data and so on
and lastly it's a platform where you can
share your samples or analyzes so if you
have a collaborative group or you would
like your colleagues to look at what
you've done using the application you
can just share the analysis with them
so where does it all start and
um it starts with the knowledge base and
ingenuity's knowledge phase is this
database of information that is
collected from a peer-reviewed
literature as well as third-party
databases and all the peer review
is done manually so we have a PhD level
scientist who reads the paper and then
adds the finding into the knowledge base
and then this knowledge base becomes the
foundation for our applications where
you can um
analyze data using variant analysis or
are more popular and widely used
application IPA
specific Ally for varying analysis that
was launched in 2012 we have curated
aside from the manual literature
findings about 350
000 manually curated human phenotype
mutation associations as well as over 20
000 curated disease models and almost
200 000 of pharmacogenetic findings
where we have informations about genes
that are targeted by specific drugs as
well as variants that are used to
determine those targets
so aside from our manual curation we
also have information from third-party
resources such as Cosmic tcta omen
MDI and others and we have in Silicon
analysis tools such as Swift polyphen
and Vista tools that are built into the
application to help with the analysis
so
in addition a kyogen also acquired
biobase which is all part of hydrogen's
bioinformatic unit and biobase brings
its GMD which is the most commonly used
Human Genome genetic mutation database
and we have now access to this database
through variant analysis so with the
subscription you have full access and
without a subscription to hdmd there is
still access to the free version through
the application
so what can you do with this knowledge
and the application together well you
can use this to analyze data sets with
Gene sequence variants
for a number of different types of
studies whether those are studies
looking at rare mendelian diseases in
trios or clots or if you have um large
categories that you're looking at you
could also have a small cohort data set
so there's a small number of cases that
you're comparing to a small number of
controls or you could have large data
sets where there are a large number of
cases and controls and what we're
introducing shortly is the ability to do
quantitative trait analysis where you
will be able to look at a variable trait
over months of samples
in addition we are able to do tumor
normal comparisons to focus on somatic
variants by removing variants that are
only that are also present in the
germline
so now I'm going to present an example
of each of these four case studies that
you can see uh and and you'll be able to
see how we're able to analyze the data
and get
to our causal variants or
pharmacogenetic targets
so starting out I'm going to present a
trio where we have a family where we had
a program a five-year-old who presented
was like medulla blastoma
he had a 27 year old normal parents with
no disease or history of megaloblastoma
in addition he had a sister who had was
diagnosed with acute myeloid leukemia
and was passed away at the age of three
so we sequenced and the proband and his
parents to determine what it is that was
passed from the parents or acquired de
novo in the child that led to
mesoblastoma
with that I'm going to now present the
analysis of the variance uploaded into
the platform and I'll go through the
different filters and Analysis settings
that were applied and just
um for the future studies I just want to
point out that I'm only going to talk
about the confidence common variance and
predict the deleterious filter in this
particular example and then um
mainly just skip to the genetic analysis
of another filters for the subsequent
studies
so starting out we looked at this data
set we uploaded the variants from the
program and the parents into the
application and had about 6 million
variants in the three samples we then
used the confidence filter
with the aim of
removing any variants that do not meet
the quality cutoffs so these are mostly
industry standard cutouts such as call
Quality of 20 or higher read depth of at
least 10 or more weeds lining up at the
varying position and also we have
ingenuities built in quality features
where we're able to remove false
positive variants
so these are variants that if you have
sequence any exomes or whole genomes you
probably seen these in genes like new
Sims or HLA or Titan these are mainly
false positives that are present due to
the large Gene families or large genes
themselves so we can remove them by
looking at exonic Windows of hundred
base pairs I'm determining them top five
percent most highly variable regions
from the Thousand genomes as well as
determining the top one percent of the
most significantly uh mutated genes or
variable genes from the Thousand genomes
now all of these settings in their
analysis where you see a little box with
arrows are changeable so if you wanted
to have a higher quality filter you
could set that to be higher if you
wanted to set your variable frequencies
to be lower uh you could set them to be
lower or if you want it to be more
stringent because your platform has much
more a false positive data you can
actually dial these up and down
next up we applied a common variant
filter so anybody who's doing a sequence
variant data analysis is aware that for
the most part we're not interested in
common variants and we want to focus on
variants that are either never seen
before or only seen in a very small
percentage of the normal population so
for that Ingenuity has built in
ability to compare your variant data to
the Thousand genomes complete genomics
publicly available data and the NHL bi
data set where you can set a frequency
cut off so here I am only focusing on
really rare variants by looking at less
than 0.1 percent variance percentage in
any of these databases again depending
on the phenotype the commonness of the
occurrence of the phenotype we can dial
this frequency up and down and as I
mentioned before this can be done in an
iterative fashion so if you set the
frequency to two percent change your
mind come back and want to dial it down
you can do it and apply it right away
and it's executed within minutes
the next thing that we would be
interested in is determining which of
these variants actually has a
consequence on the gene expression of
protein function and again we can
leverage Ingenuity of knowledge base for
that information or we can also use a
number of in silica tools that are
available to determine whether a variant
would be damaging to the gene or protein
function and we can do these separately
or or we can apply them all together as
an or filter so up top here in the first
section we're looking to see which
variance
are likely to be present in previously
known databases such as oh man or tcga
or Cosmic or have been established in
published literature should be causal or
damaging and again we apply acmg
guidelines to determine whether these
variants would be pathogenic likely
pathogenic uncertain significance or
benign
similarly we can use literature findings
as well as in silicone tools to
determine whether a variant may result
in gain of function so for example
certain variants in them
the motor region may result in increased
expression of the Gene and so we can see
if that variant is previously defined
from the knowledge base or we can use
our analytics in the Ingenuity analytics
or the sift algorithm to determine
survey in a function
furthermore if we if none of these
pressure are met if we wanted to
determine whether a variant a novel
variant is uh possibly causing disease
we can look to see if it's a frame shift
in-frame deletion or um
it could be introducing a stock or stock
put on or we could look to see if it's a
midsize variant and further check to see
if it's damaging based on a criteria
determined by cyst and polyphen we could
also look for flight sites and in
addition we can look to see if there are
any regulatory changes in the mutation
due to these variants I look for micro
rnas structural variants promoter losses
enhancers and also utr reasons
so after we have applied these three
filters you can see that we're already
down from almost 6 million variants to
about a little over a thousand so less
than 1500 variants are left at this
point we would now apply our genetic
model for further removing variants that
may not be causal
to do so we have a filter called
automatic analysis and what genetic
analysis is able to do is apply your
specific genetic model in this case I
had uploaded a pedigree to designate the
relationships of the parent to the child
and so what I can now do is only focus
on variants that Meet The mendelian
Inheritance criteria and because this is
um a child who was born to two normal
parents and has the disease and because
his sister also had the disease I'm sort
of ruling out the hypothesis that this
could be de novo and focusing on
inherited variants with a recessive
model so I'm only looking to see if
there are any causal variants that could
be
either homozygous or compound heads and
removing any variant that's a compound
had from oh sorry a homozygote in the
parent
so once we have set our genetic analysis
filter and we have reduced a number of
variants that meet that criteria to 16
in about nine genes I then can go on and
apply the biological context to this
analysis wherein I am setting the
criteria for the disease so
I'm looking to focus on variance or
genes that are previously associated
with medulloblastoma and acute myeloid
leukemia either or or both and also
looking for genes that may be one hop
Upstream of the known genes meaning we
in the knowledge base we have
information about genes that are
directly associated with modular
blastoma and acute myeloid leukemia but
we also know genes that may interact
with those known genes so we can go look
one or two hops upstream and also one or
two hops Downstream
so starting with a more conservative
approach and looking only one half
Upstream at this point I'm I'm left with
five genes with 10 variants which all
all of which mean a compound
heterozygote criteria
so if you look at this list I have
several genes that are several variants
that are in this this child and
inherited from at least one of the
parents I automatically rule out the
first one because both the variants are
coming from the same parents it's likely
not a real compound head and start with
the second Gene which is gram six which
looks like a compound hat with one
allele inherited from each of the two
parents
and start to investigate it further when
I click on the row for gram six
I get another window pop-up on my screen
that lets me have more information about
the specific variant that I highlighted
but have an option to look for a paths
to phenotype when I click on tasks to
phenotype I'm able to see how brem may
be related to one or more of the
biological context criteria that I
specified
so here it looks like gram is one half
away from acute myeloid leukemia which
was the trait that was found of the
disease that was found in the sister I
can start to see read more about the
relationship by clicking on these
vertical lines that connect them
um the two genes and also connect the
gene to the disease and by clicking on
the first line between grim and its
Target I can pull up the references that
make that connection I can click on
these links go to the abstract in PubMed
and read the publication similarly I can
click on the second line below and read
Publications that connect to Target to
acute myeloid leukemia however while
this looks like a good Target I wanted
to further explore other targets because
one of the two variants for ground six
is called out to be tolerated or benign
by stiff and polyphen so I move on to my
second candidate um in the list which is
psm2 both of these look like a good
possible causal variance because one has
a splice light loss and the other
has a stop game so when I start to
investigate psm2 I click on the paths to
phenotype for this scene and what I find
is that there are lots of relationships
between a number of genes associated
with acute myeloma leukemia as well as
medulla blastoma
and psm2 again I can further investigate
these relationships to determine how
believable and robust those are and
finally based on uh more digging
we were able to establish the psn2 is
the candidate that caused the disease in
this particular child
and possibly also his sister
so this was one example where we looked
at a trio to determine inherited disease
variants
and by taking into account family
relationships between the parent and the
child looking for mendelian inheritance
and then look and then applying the
biological contacts to look for the
appropriate genes
I'm going to now present another example
where we look at a small forward in this
example we're looking at a disease
called theochromocytoma with free
programs from extended categories with a
family history of the disease so each of
these cases presented with
theochromocytoma and had family history
and we check these three cases sequence
our exomes and compare them to
seven Hazmat control samples so these
three males and four female samples
these findings were initially made
um in 2011 and published in major
genetics however we were able to get the
sequence data and independently analyze
it using their analysis and reach to the
same conclusions as the publication
which did not use real analysis uh just
to be clear
so we get the data we uploaded and from
these seven control and three case
samples we had almost 26 000 I'm sorry
26 million variants that were uploaded
and we applied our confidence criteria
for looking at
good quality variants we applied the
common variance criteria to only focus
on variants that are not seen in the
normal population so we actually dialed
the frequency down to one percent in
this example we applied our predicted
deleterious criteria to look for known
mutations as well as look for variants
that would cause damage to protein
function
and then what then we went ahead and
applied the genetic analysis criteria so
in this case first off I wanted to
select any type of variant whether it
would be
homozygous heterozygous compound head or
any other criteria in their cases and
remove any variant that was present in
the control so we remove every variant
that would be in the control
in addition I wanted to make sure that
since these three cases have the same
disease and likely inherited disease I
wanted to see if it's possible that all
three of my cases would have a variant
in the same gene so we set the filter up
to look for any variant in the cases
that are present in the same gene for
all three of them
so at this point when we apply this
filter we're left with 24 genes with 35
variants meat that meet our criteria and
then go ahead and apply the biological
context which in this case is
theophrenocytoma
so setting the biological context in
variant analysis is very simple you just
go into the biological context filter
and type in the name of the disease or
phenotype or pathway or Gene whatever it
is that you you would like to focus on
and then to be
um in this particular example you'll see
that we'll find a direct link between
our candidate and the disease but when
we first discovered it we had actually
used two hops from the phenotype to um
look for possible novel candidate genes
for the disease and also look to see if
there were any genes that were one half
below the
known genes that are involved in here
from the cytoma in the pathway
so when I apply this criteria
um I get 19 genes with 26 variants
now as you can see on my screen several
of these variants seem to be present in
all three samples it's the same variant
that's in all of the three cases when we
further investigate their population
frequency of these variants we found
that each of these variants were rare as
in never seen before so going with the
likelihood that a novel variant would be
present in three cases all at the same
time being somewhat rare we decided to
First be a little stringent with our
criteria and apply another genetic
analysis filter so you can stack genetic
analysis filters or any other filters
that you're using to build the pipeline
for analysis
and what we decided to do here is we
said exclude any variant that's present
in all three of the three cases at the
variant level meaning we'll remove any
of the variants that look like this
when we go ahead and do that we get a
slightly cleaner table where we have
seven genes with 14 variants in all our
cases at this point we have a small
number of candidates on our screen and
we can start investigating these by
looking at paths to phenotype the for
the only one that I'm going to show you
is the one that was the published
candidate
which was also then validated by using
segregation analysis in the families
so when I look at the candidate Max
which seemed like the most possible
candidate at the time we click on it and
we find that Max is known to be directly
associated with theophilocytoma so you
can find direct links between genes and
diseases and then we can click on the
connecting line between the Gene and the
disease to investigate further by
looking at entries
um in PubMed and so we found that there
were a number of entries that connected
to Gene we also found twin bar and omim
entries for this particular uh for this
particular variants that's because the
gene has now been characterized as
um and published and we curated the
paper that published this these findings
initially
but to give you a flavor for how the
knowledge base actually found it I want
to do a little flashback
can show you how we were able to uh find
this variant independently of the paper
and the curation of the findings by
leveraging the knowledge base so when
the paper was not published and we
hadn't curated the relationship between
Max and theophrenocytoma we were able to
look up any genes that are associated
with new endocrine carcinoma because
theochromocytoma is a type of
neoendocrine carcinoma look at the genes
that are known to be associated with
fearchomocytoma from the knowledge base
and then we found Max as an interacting
partner of those genes and we're able to
establish and Max was a possible
candidate for the disease
foreign
so that's another way of looking at uh
different types of data sets where we're
doing a case control comparison removing
variants that are in the cases this can
be done when you have a small number of
places but there are scenarios where you
would have a large cohort so you have a
large number of cases and a large number
of controls we're talking hundreds and
thousands of cases and controls and for
these types of studies we will leverage
Ingenuity of yarn analysis built in
statistical Association tools
and to do so I'm about to present to you
a study that was done using samples from
the personal Genome Project the person
funeral project is a project where
volunteers enroll through sequencer
genomes the data is available through
the webs through their website the
personal genome.org
along with phenotype data for all of
these subjects so we went through the
data set and found 66 cases with myopia
and found 45 controls to match to these
cases and try to identify genes and
Pathways that may be enriched
by variance in our myopia cases
so moving on we took the data uploaded
it and again you can see here we have a
large number of variants
uploaded to the system it's over 2.6 2.7
billion variants from these nearly 100
cases that we have in the data in our
system here
we use the confidence criteria to remove
all variants that do not meet meet the
quality cutoff and then here we did
something different and I wanted to do
this differently to show you that
filters and run analysis do not have to
be in a specific order you can decide to
change the order of these skill queries
as you wish so we first look to see
which variance would be functionally
relevant and again here instead of using
the default name predicted deleterious I
changed the name to functionally
relevant just so I know what I was doing
in that particular analysis we applied
the criteria to look for
variance that may be previously known to
be causing disease as well as variants
that would cause loss or gain of
function of the gene
I then went on to remove the common
variance by applying the common variance
filter and here I've called it rare
variance because I'm only focusing on
variants that are in five percent or
less of the population and then I went
to apply uh instead of applying the
genetic analysis filter I use
statistical Association
the most statistical Association filter
has is it has built-in tools to apply
different statistical models for your
analysis so one you can do is a burden
test which is up top here and with the
burden test we can look for burden of
variance in either genes or Pathways so
here I'm doing a gene burden test and we
can look for burden of variance in
either cases controls or both cases and
controls using the scat-o algorithm
that's built into the application
in addition if you actually just wanted
to do a common variance association test
we also have their test builds in here
using
bonferoni or benjamini Hotspur
Corrections for multiple testing and
this will just see if there are specific
variants Associated to your cases or
controls just like you would do in a
jiwa study
so once we apply in this example we are
looking to see what their variants may
be enriched in specific genes or
Pathways in this case genes I go on to
the next step and then
um I get I actually get 11 genes with 73
variants that are enriched in the cases
and then I went ahead and applied all
biological contexts relevant for myopia
eye disease eye development eye
morphology just to be as Broad in in my
analysis as possible and I've got five
genes with 29 variants so you can see
that on my screen here I'm looking at
the juice table with the five genes that
are linked to myopia as a result of my
burden test and here's a list of
variance and number of cases and
controls that carry those variants
so now I can start examining each of
these in more detail to see how they may
be Associated to myopia and here's the
list of the genes with the specific
variants I'm going to show you the first
one
um which is the
I'm practicing in that in that we were
able to see that it is associated to a
number of phenotype and myopia-related
uh disease conditions through a large
number of known genes that cause these
disease or development
of eye
what I was more intrigued by In This
analysis was the hk3 gene because as you
can see here hk3 Gene seems to have an
enrichment of this variant in most of
its cases initially I was tempted to
dismiss this as a sequence artifact but
then when I found that there is actually
a population frequency of one to two
percent I
um it seemed like I'm more of a real
enrichment so here we have a missense
variant that is enriched in on most of
my myopia cases and when I investigate
the gene it looks like a good candidate
as it's involved in morphology of eye
and eye development through these two
known genes um that are associated with
the phenotypes and pathways so that that
made it a good candidate and here you
can see a view of all the cases with the
variant the fall quality and we can see
that these are all good quality calls so
this is likely not a sequence artifact
that may have been observed
so that was a study where we were able
to identify a candidate for a common
phenotype by using a statistical
sequence in a number of larger number of
cases and controls and a statistical
burden task and look for enrichment of
variance in cases before I move on to
case number four I I'm just going to
quickly see if there's a question that I
can address
um so there is a question that's asking
about normalizing for
um
de seek and it's our algorithms as input
I'm not that is not currently built into
the application but if you had a values
Associated for those as vet files for
specific variants you can upload them
into the application and filter that
so last case that I'm going to present
today is a pair trip to a normal study
and for this we're using two cell lines
and
from for breast cancer and we have two
breast cancer cell lines matched with
their normal cell line so you can see
these are the tumor cell lines and these
are the normal cell lines and of course
somatic variant analysis what we do is
we Max samples by their
subject IV so that would suggest that
these two case these two samples are
from the same individual and then those
two samples are from the same individual
and this way their application Paris
them and only removes a germline variant
if it's present in the Matched normal
and not in the other normal
so once again we sequence these with
complete genomics so this is we got hold
genome data
and we were able to then go ahead and
filter for confidence common variance
and apply the genetic analysis filter
which I'm going to show you here so here
we applied a somatic variance filter so
this is a tumor specific filter and what
this is designed to do is first off hair
mask for examples by individuals so each
of those two tumor normal pairs got
matched to each other
and we then went ahead and removed any
variant that was present in the max
normal
from the analysis and this was done so
that only if the variant is present in
the match normal and the tumor will it
be removed otherwise it will be retained
if it was a somatic variant only
we then had the ability to apply a
cancer driver variance filter so this is
a special filter that I was talking
about earlier which is designed
specifically for analyzing cancer data
and what we have here is the ability to
look for variants in genes that are
associated with cancer knockout models
in mice that are known to be associated
with processes and Pathways for cancer
as well as if any genes are specifically
known targets for Therapeutics any
published findings also we are able to
include information from cosmic and tcpa
to this very analysis
once we apply the cancer driver filter
we're now focusing only on the 1500 plus
genes that are known cancer drivers or
those that interact with these known
cancer survivors we then apply our
specific biological context for breast
cancer and are able to reduce the number
of genes to 209 that's still a lot of
Dreams especially if I was interested in
focusing on therapeutic targets
so I can do further analysis to narrow
down from this list of 209 to those that
would be relevant for my study so first
off because in my predicted deleterious
filter I had applied the criteria to
include anything that was likely
pathogenic and uncertain significance I
now want to remove anything that is
non-coding so first off I'm removing
anything that's in a promoter or in the
utr and I'm doing this by applying a
second predicted deleterious filter
where I set it to exclude promoters and
um
utr variants so that will reduce my list
of genes to 87 so these 87 genes all
have coding variants next up I want to
focus on those that are targets for
pharmacogenetic findings so if there is
a drug that is known to Target the
specific gene or variant and I come down
to 44 genes and this is done using the
pharmacogenetic filter
where I'm looking for any dreams that
are associated with response toxicity or
metabolism our targets or any other drug
binding
um relationships that are known I can
also apply I can also type and name of
specific drugs to further limit this
list of those that are known targets of
badura and by doing so I now go down to
44 genes and I can then investigate each
of these variants in genes by clicking
on the pharmacogenetic findings to see
which drugs were used how those drugs
were associated to that particular gene
or variant and then these can be used as
a therapeutic targets either for
research purposes or in the clinical
settings to see which are the best drugs
to be applied
so with that I would
I like to end the top and just do a
little quick recap so what we saw here
today was an application that was used
to capture either causal variants or
targets or variants or G and genes
associated with different diseases or
phenotypes and to recap the key features
off the application it's a very secure
application so all data that you upload
is stored on our secure servers it is
not residing on your laptop it's
residing in our servers that are both
HIPAA compliant and have safe harbor
you also have the ability to do a really
fast and interactive filtering and
Analysis of your data by applying
quality cutoffs common variance cutoffs
focusing on causal variants that would
have a deleterious effect on the Gene
and then really put those variants into
the biological context
we can also
um then share our analyzes with our
colleagues so you can either share
uploaded samples with your colleagues or
you can analyze the data and then share
the analysis with your colleagues who
can review it make changes and uh
initiate collaborative discussions for
the data that you look at and lastly
it's a very supported product so if you
have any questions or concerns about
your analysis understanding what you
look at or any technical issues you can
reach out to Ingenuity for um technical
as well as scientific support and with
that I'm going to end and take any
questions that you all may have
no other questions
foreign
I am going to end the session if you do
think of something please feel free to
reach out to us at support ingenuity.com
oh I see a question popping up
oh great questions
um
the first question I have here is what
are the input formats for varying
analysis and so variant analysis will
take your VCF files that are generated
through the geotkit pipeline it will
take complete genomics Master bar and
high confidence Junction files as well
as Illumina and gvf Files The genome
varying files and how long does it take
to complete the analyzes
um so the length of uh the course of
time taken to complete the analysis
depends on the number of samples and the
complexity of the data so with a smaller
data set about 100 or a couple hundred
usually you're done within 15-20 minutes
to an hour larger data sets of thousands
of samples
um especially if there are thousands of
whole genome samples it may take a while
a few hours for them to be done either
way once you set up your analysis you
can log out of the application and you
will be notified by an email once your
analysis is done
um so I have a question about the hcmv
database could you be more specific
about
what you're looking for
so the htmg database basically has
information about known genetic
mutations that are associated with
disease phenotypes so what we're able to
incorporate an ingenuitive yarn analysis
at this time is if you have a variant in
your data set that's also present in
hvmd you will see a link to that variant
so let me go back to um one of my slides
and show you where you will find that
information so
so this window when it pops up if you
have a variant that's also present in
hdmd it will be indicated with the htmv
accession number just down here and then
you will be able to click on that link
uh to see to read more about that
variant from the database
if that variant is in the free data set
and you don't have a license however if
you have full access you will be able to
get all the information there is in the
htmd database about all variants the
future plan for hcmd is uh with regards
to variant analysis is to incorporate it
in the application so you will be able
to filter your variants against what is
already present in the database
um there's a question about applying
these features to analysis of other
organisms unfortunately at this time the
application is only able to take and
analyze Human Genome data so we're not
able to analyze other organisms uh
accuracy of the analysis uh that's a
good question but
so accuracy is really is a bit of a
subjective uh question what we're able
to do with the application is really get
you as much information about the
variant to make a call whether that is a
candidate or not so we're able to put it
into the context of
the disease and the pathway and also
we're able to apply analytical criteria
such as if it fits the inheritance model
that you would expect it to fit and as
far as the analyzes is concerned it
picks up the variance accurately so if a
covariant was transmitted from the
parent it will be appropriately filtered
into your data and you will be able to
analyze it further as far as the
biological context is concerned that
knowledge faces as accurate as the
actual published literature is if there
is public information about ovarian
there will be more information that
there will be accurate information about
that variant in the database
I hope that answered your question
so we do run internal algorithms as well
so
um sorry because the next question that
I have here is is all the information
from the knowledge base or do we run
internal algorithms so we run internal
algorithms to determine what variance
should be retained for further
biological analysis so for example our
algorithms will determine whether
variants are causing gain or function or
we're running algorithms to determine if
the variance fits the inheritance
pattern that you're looking at so if you
were trying to see
um if a variant was coming from the
parent or whether it's a somatic variant
versus a variant that was inherited in
from the germline or if you have a large
cohort and you're trying to see all the
um
cases have a burden for a variance in a
particular Gene all those analyzes are
derived through uh internal algorithms
that Ingenuity has built in
foreign
trial version we have a 30 minute brief
preview for your data so if you upload
your data into the system you can set up
an analysis and once the analysis is
done you will get a 30 minutes to go
through all the filter settings and get
to your list of candidate barriers this
is to give you a flavor for how the
application works if there was more
interest in trying it out we do have uh
nominal charges for paid Pilots to test
out the application and if you're
interested you could email us and we can
set you up with the right person to talk
to
more questions
foreign
there are no more questions we can end
the session and uh thank you all for
your time and um please feel free to
reach out to us if anything else comes
up after this thanks
foreign